while relations between North and South
Korea remain tense a day after Pyongyang
threatened to restart military exercises
in the Demilitarized Zone tensions on
the Korean Peninsula hit a new low on
Tuesday when Pyongyang blew up its joint
liaison office with Seoul up until a
year ago the two had been making steps
toward a more peaceful coexistence
there's little sign of any of that now
it was hailed as the big moment of peace
and reconciliation the opening of the
north south korea joint liaison office
in September 2018 part of the two
countries efforts to reduce tensions on
the peninsula
now those hopes and the building lie in
ruins the two countries are technically
still at war that 50-year old conflict
ended in the truce not an actual peace
treaty after years of peace efforts a
breakthrough came with the South Korean
2018 Winter Olympics the two rivals even
announced the creation of a single
unified women's ice hockey team to enter
the games hopes kept growing with an
inter-korean summit a few months later
Chong yang in Seoul promised to pursue a
denuclearization of the peninsula
there were even talks of a permanent
peace deal then the moment many thought
would never happen a u.s. president
setting foot on North Korean soil Donald
Trump held face-to-face meetings with
the North's Kim jong-un
but the much-hyped talks didn't amount
to much last November the North again
increased its long-range missile tests
but win North Korean defectors based in
South Korea recently sent balloons with
propaganda leaflets across the border
Pyongyang threatened with consequences
even military action the comments
announced on North Korean TV were
attributed to Kim Jong Un's
influential sister kim yo-jong not the
leader himself she's a close ally who's
become one of the regime's most powerful
voices in recent years these latest
developments are not only a big setback
to ongoing peace efforts but also a
personal defeat for South Korea's
president moon jae-in whose
administration had been pushing for
further engagement with the north and
let's get more now we are joined by
Robert Kelley who is a political analyst
on inter-korean affairs and an associate
professor in political science at Pusan
National University he joins us now
welcome to the program tell us because
we have North Korea threatening to move
its military into the demilitarized
border areas how high is the risk of a
further escalation umm well them the
movement back wouldn't actually be too
big a deal the two Koreas signed in the
last couple years
a few agreements to sort of retrench a
little bit back from the demilitarized
on the Demilitarized Zone assist the
strip that runs right through the middle
of the country and there's no military
forces there well there are but not much
there the real issue is that the North
Koreans had sort of offered so to begin
to sort of pull back a little bit
they've got an enormous amount of force
very close to the South Korean capital
and that looks like it will be unwound
but it doesn't really threaten South
Korean security very much I think the
real issue in the in the next eight
months or so maybe six months to a year
is whether or not the North Koreans will
actually launch some kind of armed
provocation against South Korea they've
done this kind of stuff for decades um
that hasn't happened in several years I
think that's the real possible
escalatory step that people worry about
Pyongyang saying that the tensions are
over North Korean defectors sending
propaganda over the border that's
nothing new
so I mean why why is this happening now
yeah it's probably not because of the
leaf
the North Koreans have endured that for
they don't like it obviously and they've
taken actions against it in the past but
but the demolition of the building
probably wasn't really about that I
think it was really sort of a signal and
there's been a buildup of North Korean
rhetoric in the last few months and I
think this is sort of a culmination of
that rhetoric there's been this sort of
effort to sort of get moon Jane the
president of South Korea to act
independently of the Americans in the
international community and strike a
deal on North Korea the North Koreans
really want sanctions relief but moon
Jane really can't do that because one
legally he's bound by the rules at the
UN and then politically he's bound by
this for constraints of the American
alliance the Alliance is very popular in
South Korea and so even if moon would
like to go off and do something
independently he really can't because he
would face massive blowback here and so
this is kind of left him stuck and the
North Koreans have been pushing and kind
of bullying him and this was the latest
step in that that's what this is really
about they're trying to get a deal out
of the South okay so they're trying to
get a deal let's talk about the face
also that has become very prominent in
all of this the face of last week's
escalation it's been not North Korean
leader Kim jong-un as we might expect
but rather his sister why is that yeah
there's so there's a lot of speculation
about this right sort of the the rise of
the sister in the background and the
most obvious reason probably is because
North Korea is a bloodline monarchy and
she is the most obvious person to take
over in that we don't know if Kim
jong-un has children there's sort of
rumor people think he does but they
would be too young right and so we kind
of assumed that the sister would have to
sort of take over there's a sort of an
interesting debate there about whether
or not the North Korean elites could
sort of accept the female ascension that
sort of another issue I oh that's that
that's one thing right because she's
close to Kim
she has sort of taken over stuff just
because of the bloodline relationship
and then also I think to a certain
extent Kim jong-un wants to avoid
personally putting his hands on this
mess because if it does things do turn
around if things do get better you can
say oh you know that was my sister right
I'm still interested in peace so it's
kind of like a good cop bad cop okay and
I think so he has some plausible
deniability there Robert Kelley in Busan
putting all these tensions on the Korean
Peninsula into perspective for us so we
thank you very much for sharing your
expertise today thank you for having me
for let's bring in correspondent Frank
Smith in Seoul g'day to you Frank can
you take us through this latest
escalation how did we get to this point
well we need to go back to 2018 when we
had a couple of summits several summits
some between North Korean leader Kim
jong-un and US President Donald Trump
but for our purposes today the two
summits or three summits between South
Korean president moon jae-in and North
Korean leader Kim jong-un and they drew
up the so-called pan moon jom
Declaration and part of that involved a
drawdown of tension along the border an
elimination of propaganda activities
that had taken place you know between
the two Koreas including things like
loudspeakers set up along the border
blasting anti-north Korea messages
toward the north from the south and the
dismantling of guard posts on both sides
of the heavily militarized DMZ one of
the activities that had continued since
that time is the flying of leaflets
across the border by balloon by South
Korean NGOs nongovernmental
organizations led by North Korean
defectors one of those groups is led by
bak Jung oh and he sends rice and
medicine in some [ __ ]
sometimes lately anti coronavirus masks
in plastic bottles by the ocean and I
had a chance to talk to him earlier this
week North Korean defector Park jeong-ho
has been sending rice and medicine to
North Korea in plastic bottles using
ocean currents for four years now
following Pyongyang's recent complaints
South Korean officials have vowed to
stop such activities but Pok is
undeterred I don't know why the
government is trying to stop this now
they should say that there is nothing
they can do because this is a
non-governmental group activity I think
it would be wrong to suppress such
organizations because of what was said
by North Korea's Kim Yu
young I'm confused whether I live here
in Seoul or in Pyongyang okay Lee Jung
goes brother Park sang Hawk has been
sending leaflets critical of the Kim
regime by balloon over the border for
more than a decade
the two brothers fled North Korea some
20 years ago in call for South Korea to
push back against Pyongyang critics
though argued that actions like theirs
only provoke North Korea activists like
those gathered here today outside the
blue house South Korea's presidential
compound show the stark division in
public opinion over how to deal with
North Korea some advocate a hard-line
approach while others like most of those
gathered here today favor renewed
efforts at engagement and peacemaking
this civic group is calling for
president moon jae-in to implement the
deals he made in two landmark summits
with North Korean leader Kim jong-un in
2018 which includes suspending
cross-border propaganda no matter what
kind of non-governmental organization is
involved
the South Korean government can stop
them and the South Korean government
should stop them from sending fliers to
North Korea and should implement the pan
moon drum declaration after North Korea
Tuesday blew up the joint liaison office
in Kaesong just inside North Korea South
Korea offered to send an envoy a move
which was rejected by the north defector
Park jeong-ho is against any further
attempts at appeasement and wants South
Korea to stand up to North Korea if we
kneel North Korea will continue to move
in the same direction if we stay strong
our fifty million people can be free
from threats we need to have the
confidence of a sovereign state because
they are a card in the world
as the tension simmers and despite
warnings police will interfere Park
still plans to monitor the tide and send
bottles of rice to North Korea
Frank Pyongyang's blaming the tensions
on North Korean defectors like Park
jeong-ho who sent propaganda across the
border but this isn't anything new so so
why the harsh response from the north
well we're hearing a lot of different
analysis here in South Korea it's hard
to really divine North Korea's reasoning
behind some of its policies especially
in this case if we look at a couple of
things first of all kovat 19 has gripped
by many reports North Korea and so the
regime might be trying to distract
people from that but a lot of analysts
are saying this is messaging to the
United States over the ongoing United
Nations Security Council sanctions
against North Korea that prevent North
Korea from engaging the international
community especially in terms of
commerce so that's the the primary
takeaway it's not necessarily just about
these leaflets but it's about that that
greater issue of North Korea's isolation
now in front of the cameras the face of
the latest escalation has not been North
Korean leader Kim jong-un but instead
his sister kim yo-jong why is she
playing such a prominent role right now
well I think if we go back a month or
two ago when the reports came out in
North Korea that Kim jong-un was gravely
ill that later proved to be you know
somewhat false we were asking ourselves
who would be the next leader of North
Korea at that time guy interviewed isang
hyung of the Sejong Institute just
outside of Seoul and he said that if we
hear about kim yo-jong achievements in
her policy if she's more present in
North Korean propaganda then that means
she is more than likely the presumptive
heir to the North Korean regime to the
Kim dynasty and that's certain
what we've seen in this recent cycle of
escalated tension on the Korean
Peninsula Frank Smith's thanks much for
that from Seoul